in fact she could never resign herself
to buying anything from which one could
not drive an intellectual prophet and
especially that much beautiful things
afford us by teaching us to seek our
pleasure elsewhere than the
satisfactions of material comfort and
vanity
even when she had to make someone a
present of the kind called useful when
she had to give an armchair silverware a
walking stick she looked for old ones as
though now that long destituted to face
their character of usefulness they would
appear more disposed to tell us about
the life of people of other times to
deserve the needs of our own life
she would have liked me to have in my
room photographs the most beautiful
monuments or landscapes but at the
moment of buying them and even though
the thing represented had an aesthetic
value she would find that vulgarity and
utility too quickly resumed in their
places and that mechanical mode of
representation the photograph
she would try to use cunning and if not
to eliminate commercial bananaly
entirely at least to reduce it to
substitute for the greater part of it
more art
to introduce into in a sense several
layers of art instead of photographs of
charles cathedral the fountains of san
cru or mount vesuvius should make
inquiries of swan as to whether some
great painter had not depicted them and
preferred to give me photographs of
shark cathedral by corral the fountains
of san cle by uber robert of mount
vesuvius by turner which made one
further degree of art
but if the photographer had been removed
from the representation of the
masterpiece or of nature replaced by a
great artist he still reclaimed his
rights to reproduce that very
interpretation
having deferred vulgarity as far as
possible my grandmother would try to
move it back still further
she would ask swan if the work had not
been engraved preferring wherever
possible old engravings that also had an
interest beyond themselves
such as those that represent a
masterpiece in a state in which we can
no longer see it today like the
engraving by morgan of leonardo's last
supper before its deterioration
it must be said that the results of this
interpretation of the art of gift giving
were not always brilliant
the idea formed a venice from a drawing
by titan that is supposed to have a
lagoon in the background was certainly
far less accurate than the one i would
have derived from simple photographs
we could not keep count at home and my
great aunt wanted to drop an indictment
against my grandmother the armchair she
presented young couples engaged to be
married or old married couples which is
the first attempt to make use of them
had immediately collapsed under the
weight of one of the recipients
but my grandmother would have believed
that petty to be overly concerned about
the solidity of a piece of wood which
one could still distinguish a small
flower a smile sometimes a lovely
invention from the past
even what might in these pieces of
furniture answer a need since it did so
in a matter to which we're no longer
accustomed gender like the old ways of
speaking in which we see a metaphor that
is obliterated in our modern language by
the aberration of habit
now in fact the pastoral novels of
george sand that she was giving me for
my saints day were like an old piece of
furniture full of expressions that had
fallen into disuse and turned figurative
again
the sword no longer find anywhere but in
the country
and my grandmother had bought them in
preference to others just as she would
sooner have rented an estate on which
there was a gothic dove code or another
those old things that exercise such a
happy influence in the mind by filling
it with longing for impossible voyages
through time
mama sat down by my bed
she had picked up josue whose reddish
cover an incomprehensible title gave it
to my eyes a distinct personality and a
mysterious attraction i not yet read a
real novel
i had heard people say that george sam
was an exemplary novelist this already
predisposed me to imagine something
indefinable indefinable and delicious in
france
narrative devices intended to arouse
curiosity or emotion
certain modes of expression that make
one uneasy or melancholy that a reader
with some education will recognize as
common in many novels appeared to me who
considered a new book not a thing not as
a thing having many counterparts but as
a unique person having no reason for
existing but in itself simply is a
disturbing emanation of frost water
shelby's peculiar essence
behind those events so ordinary those
things so common those words so currents
i sensed a strange sort of intonation
accentuation
the action began it seemed to me all the
more obscure because in those days when
i read i often daydream for entire pages
of something quite different
and in addition to the lacunae that this
distraction left in the story there was
the fact when mama was the one reading
aloud to me that she skipped all the
love scenes
there's all the bizarre changes that
take place in the respective attitudes
of the miller's wife and the child that
can be explained only by the progress of
a nascent love seem to me marked by
profound mystery whose source directly
imagined must be in that strange and
sweet name champio which gave the child
who wore without my knowing why it's
vivid charming purplish color
my mother was an unfaithful reader she
was also in the case of books in which
she found the inflection of true failing
a wonderful reader
for the respect and simplicity of her
interpretation the beauty and gentleness
of the sound of her voice
even in real life when it was people and
all works of art which moved into
compassion or admiration it was touching
to see with what deference she removed
from her voice from her emotions from
her words any spark of gaiety that might
hurt some mother who had once lost a
child
any recollection of a saints day or
birthday that might remind some old man
of his advanced stage any remark about
housekeeping that might seem tedious to
some young scholar in the same way when
she was reading georgetown's prose which
always breathes that goodness that moral
distinction with mama had learned from
my grandmother to consider superior to
all else in life which i was to teach
her only much later not to consider
superior to all else in books too
taking care to banish from her voice any
pettiness any affectation which might
have prevented it from receiving that
powerful torrent she imparted all the
natural tenderness all the ample
sweetness they demanded to those
sentences which seemed written for her
voice and which remained so to speak
entirely within the register of her
sensibility
she found to attack them in an asses
necessary tone the warm inflection that
pre-exists them and that dictated them
but that the words do not indicate
with this inflection she softened as she
went along any crudes in the tenses of
the verbs gave the imperfect in the past
historic the sweetness that lies in
goodness
the melancholy that lies in tenderness
directed the sentence that was ending
toward the one that was about to begin
sometimes hurrying sometimes slowing
down the pace of the syllables
so as to bring them through their
quantity though their quantities were
very different into one uniform rhythm
she breathed into this very common
prayer as a sort of continuous emotional
life
my remorse was quiet i gave into the
sweetness of that night in which i had
my mother close to me
i knew that such a night could not be
repeated that the greatest desire i had
in the world to keep my mother in the
room during those sad hours of darkness
was too contrary to the necessities of
life and the wishes of others for its
fulfillment
granted this night to be anything other
than artificial and exceptional
tomorrow my anxieties would reawaken and
my mom would not stay here
but when my anxieties were soothed i no
longer understood them and then tomorrow
night was still far away
i told myself i would have time to think
of what to do
even though that time could not bring me
any access of power since these things
did not depend on my will
and seemed more avoidable only to me
only because of the interval that still
separated them from me
you